Grüß Gott!
Ja, wo ist der Patient?
Berti, komm rein! Gleich sind wir da, Berti. Komm nur rein!
Da sind wir schon. Komm nur Berti, komm!
Ja, wen haben Sie uns denn da mitgebracht?
Ja, das ist der Berti. Und ihm geht's nicht gut.
Frau Doktor hilft dir gleich. Gell, Berti?
Das ist ein Saugroboter ...
Ja, aber wischen kann er auch.
Eigentlich bin ich nur für, für ...
Ja, ich weiß schon, so Hunde und Katzen und so. Aber ich weiß ja nicht, wo ich hingehen soll mit ihm.
Bitte könnten Sie ihn mal anschauen. Bitte!
Die Frau Doktor hilft dir schon!
Also, was genau fehlt ihm denn?
Eine Hausstauballergie?
Nein!
Nein?
Der Saugroboter hat ihn gefressen!
Wer hat wen gefressen?
Der Saugroboter hat meinen Zwerghamster gefressen!
Was denn sonst?
Berti! Die Frau Doktor hilft dir. Keine Angst!
Ich mach gleich mal OP-fertig ...
Gell Berti, das wird schon.